well being a top player I mean I think
he has many but obviously very good
opening preparation and good nerves and
I think very balanced style playing you
know or some of his best qualities well
it's definitely a world-class player
he's a player as I said he hasn't played
that many high level tournaments
recently he's a great irritation I think
back then he plays like one e4 with
white quite almost exclusively but with
very good results and he's very good in
tactics and he's also a great rapid and
bliss player because he played in Qatar
last year I think he did very well there
and also he did quite quite well the st.
Louis rapid inlets it's difficult when
you face a very strong position and a
player like Wesley of course is one of
the best and you kind of have to prepare
for really no mistakes from your
opponent so I'm trying to focus on my
own game try to do two to play as as
good as possible and to keep focused all
the time try to save some energy because
it's it's going it's going to be tiring
I mean 30 games maybe the third or
fourth day it will be kind of difficult
that hopefully I'll get some some
chances